so why was it so important for you to
keep this promise because it sounds like
it wasn't an easy road and we can go
into more of that later but I would love
to just talk about your need to keep
your word and you know especially an
entertainment that doesn't always happen
yeah what was so important to you to
keep your word with this like why I
think it's just something I've grown up
with I went through the Boy Scouts and
got my eagle scout award and it's just
something that is instilled in you and
so I think you know one of the Scout Law
principles is trustworthy so you know
Here I am being trusted to finish this
thing and I shook hands I gave my word
so every time I looked about you looked
at quitting or looked at like moving on
or doing something else or like just
sending an email and being like it's
just not going to happen I didn't and I
was just like you know I gave my word I
gotta push through I got to finish
whatever it is I got to get through
whatever unbelievable drama gets put in
front of me there has to be a solution
somewhere and so I did and I just kept
pushing on and kept pushing on and and
got through it how long was the process
again well we shot the film in August
2008 August in September and had our
world premiere in january two thousand
or in March 2013 so good five year five
year effort and then you know after our
premier getting the DVD out and you know
here we are in april 2014 so I
relationship Wow and I can see how proud
you are when you hold up that beautiful
DVD yeah he's awesome and then there's a
lot of extras in a menu and it's really
nice so what did the whole process
teaching you excuse me what did the
whole process teach you about not
quitting about staying the course
uh well and I think about that a lot I
think about well well what you know I
think ultimately like sometimes it's not
the best decision to keep a promise
really i think you know sometimes it is
best to just just call it and do
something else because i feel like
several years of my life have been
involved in getting this thing finished
and i've i've passed on amazing amazing
opportunities that'll never get back you
know amazing travel opportunities and
shooting the world cup down in south
africa and traveling and of course you
balance it all right like now it's done
and you're like wow it would have never
gotten finished if I didn't stay with it
but it's hard to it's hard to look back
and say what you would change or what
you would do differently of course in
the moment you're always making the best
decision you can and in the moment I
always felt like I can't give up I can't
give up I can't give up so and sort of
this there's this motto or this advice
don't give up don't give up don't give
up so in my mind I'm always like wow I
should just follow that I she just
followed ash so
you